here we are in my allotment and I've set
up three Dalek compost bins hopefully
this one is the perfect Unix
and I'm going to show you what that what
I consider to be a good mix I've got
some very coarse woody wood chip in here
which is going to provide structure and
aeration because the other stuff I'm
putting it in it's just my kitchen caddy
here which is all the stuff out the
kitchen
general peelings eggshells bits of paper
you can see there's banana skins is a
bit of bread try not to put in cooked
food but a little bit it's not going to
be a problem and then I want to mix that
up well layer it in with more woody
stuff make sure that that's going to
provide the Airways throughout it okay
so there's quite a lot of wet sloppy
stuff in there I try and level it off as
much as possible and as I say mix it
keep mixing it next up you can use
scrunched up paper certain amount of
that as well but it's gonna lose its
structure so you do need to have some
chunky stuff ideally to help keep the
Airways there you can have old plants to
dry plant stems all that kind of thing
as well so this one isn't I've been
doing for a couple of months now and
hopefully is a good mix of stuff this
one here is mostly dried materials from
paper and plant stems that kind of thing
and that one's just squishy food waste
some stuff from the kitchen all that
kind of thing all the peelings and that
kind of thing so what I would like to do
now hasn't been done yet cameras on it
is to lift this up and show you what
it's like and hopefully this would be
quite nice now let's have a look if I
can lift it up
should come up like a sandcastle
yeah well that's looking pretty good you
can see that there's a nice structure
through it there's various bits of plant
growing there's a bit of bindweed there
which shouldn't have got in there it's
potato growing but generally speaking
it's been quite warm and it's looking
like it's starting to make compost
obviously the bit on the top
the most recent bit needs a lot more
composting but down here just in the
last couple of months
it's starting to turn into something
resembling compost and there's even some
worms in there I haven't put any worms
in here they will find your compost and
they will if they're if they're they
like it they will be in there and they
will breed up so there we go so that's
looking good so this one that's too dry
and it's got ants in it I can see the
ants already which is a sure sign that
it's too dry I put quite a lot of wood
chip in there now you can tell it's too
dry look it's unlike the other one which
was really quite
and it is starting to compost down there
this one is just falling apart and it's
far too drying so that's okay because we
can just mix that into another compost
heap this one here is probably going to
be the most interesting it's just been
pretty much food waste stuff from the
kitchen on its own yuck
that's very smelly too isn't it tell
smell straight away that's really gone
anaerobic you can see that easy juicy
stuff down the bottom there it's really
not very pleasant at all it's kind of it
looks like it's been preserved doesn't
it like a jelly or something and it's
not composting at all it's just sat
there going very anaerobic and slowly so
you can see the clear difference here
really to dry then the camera can't
really see round this side but around
this side of them okay masses and masses
kind of paper that's not done anything
well compost eventually the worms are in
there look the worms are started getting
in with enough moisture in there enough
water it will eventually break down that
but this one is just sodden and wet and
it really needs breaking up an air
rating so if we mix those two together
we're gonna get a good we're gonna get a
good mixture so what I could do now is
just combine them make quite a mess here
but put it put them all back into one
Dalek bin and then it will start to
compost like this one house with a
particularly wet example Nicky I love
see you suggest use of wood chip to dry
it out and get the right mix so there
any other sort of carbon mix dry sort of
ingredients you could add to it I
noticed maybe cardboard could help the
cardboard is great cardboard is really
good I put some cardboard in in this one
the trouble with cardboard is once it's
got wet it'll soak up the moisture once
it's got wet it's got no structure
there's no air in there and you get this
squidgy ball don't you
it's just nothing there's nothing
there's no air that can get in there
sodden cargo would really value where do
you need a mixture you know you find
plenty of things like dry plant stems in
your garden you can save them through
that through the year save them up put
them to one side they'll store for
forever because they're dry and woody so
they'll be fine and as long as you mix
that with it you've got little snorkels
of air going through you know here's
some I just picked these up off the path
you know if you don't tidy up your
garden in your term
you're leaving nice habitats for insects
anyway through the winter and then come
the spring when things start growing
it's not collecting them up and or
mixing them through your compost as you
go you know that's that's what I do and
it's very simple actually to find dry
stuff there's plenty of Twiggy staff can
use hedge prunings
all your kind of pruning something
that's a bit tougher you don't need a
lot of it and especially when it's
combined with the cardboard you're
getting the absorption from the
cardboard and you're getting the air
channels there's snorkelling through and
breaking apart and if you really can't
get enough of it then you've got to get
in there with a fork and dig it over and
aerate it and add more paper and
cardboard then but as I can say you
really need something structural if the
worst comes to worst go and buy yourself
a bag of bark chips you know and then
you can always sieve it out at the end
of the composting process would yes
there's an ideal ratio between the sort
of dry carbon rich material and the more
wet nitrogen rich material like food
waste
kind of depends on what exactly what
what the stuff is but very roughly rule
of thumb is so about 50/50 really by
volume by volume so I had a nice you
know I had a kind of bucket full of that
stuff perhaps a bit you know and I
probably had a and I had a you know a
bucket full of that stuff roughly the
same volume really but it does depend I
mean it was quite a bit of paper and
other bits in with my kitchen stuff
anyway so I didn't put quite so much of
the hard chunky stuff in there's
something you get a feel for in the end
and you just sort of know when it's
happening right here advisable each time
you put food waste into into your Darla
compost bin then you would follow that
up with some wood ship or dry materials
so you're really forming a layer but
then you'd also mix it up as you put the
two in so they're mixed together